gegen den lock down blues haben sich die
deutschen im letzten jahr über eine
million haustiere geholt vor allem hunde
sind gefragt kann das gut gehen
zu risiken und nebenwirkungen frage ich
beim profi nahm
wer glauben sie braucht mehr
psychologische hilfe die grünen stellen
sich über ausreden ist so ja klar
also ich muss jetzt nicht meinen
erklären mit ihnen besser umzugehen ich
muss ihnen erklären wie sie mit meinen
hunden umzugehen haben die grünen in
bremen die fordern ja einen
hundeführerschein
was halten sie davon ja wenn er gut
ausgeklügelt ist von menschen die auch
wirklich ahnung davon haben und nicht
von menschen die überhaupt keine ahnung
davon haben wir das eine supersache
ja ich meine wir haben ja auch um
führerschein für ein kraftfahrzeug um
halt eben die sicherheit zu
gewährleisten also warum nicht mit und
auch also es wäre schon sehr wichtig
sollen abgesehen davon haben wir ein
bisschen sicherheit damit na da kann man
auch ein bisschen zumindest hat eben
schon okay wer führt ja eigentlich und
sollte man dann auch wie beim
führerschein so einen idiotentest
einführen weil auch erkennt man die
idioten ja schon an der hunderasse nein
überhaupt zeigen wieso das wäre ja so
leute die so wie pitbulls umlauf was das
noch keine idioten haben wir etwa einen
hunderassen oder wie den hund brauchen
sie dennoch oder würden sie den abgeben
es sind sie verrückt jetzt mal rein
theoretisch wenn wir jetzt hier durch
den durch den park der die würde ich das
schaffen dass ein fremder hund auf mich
zuläuft und ich den sozusagen also dann
mitnehmen kann ist das super und zwar
hab ich ja stimmen hat und jetzt schnell
sich das aber nein ich spiele damit dass
man sich ja auch das was ich auch das
mache ich auch und ist damit weglaufen
weglaufen lauf
jetzt haben sie ihn und ich interessiere
mich nicht für die ja dass er das bester
ich interessiere mich gar nicht für den
100 stand jetzt viel toller der stock
ist aber schön dass ich auch mit dem
schachspiel nein das damals sehr sie
dürften da habe ich mit dem stock sei in
der es mir den stock ist der stock toll
jetzt konnte an auf normal
eins muss ich mal sagen bitte ich sie
aus erwähnten vogelscheuche sie haben
wunderschöne habe ist also hat da jemand
vom spezialfutter für glänzendes fell
genascht ich habe ich habe die genetik
meiner mutter geerbt zum glück bin ich
in einem vater der er war schon mit
anfang 20 km
sie haben ja vier genau da kann man ja
einen abgeben was ich machen kann ist
dass ich sie male alleine in die hand
geben lernen wie ein bisschen einführung
wenn sie mögen ja einfach hier so gerade
reingreifen mit der rechten hand
reingreifen jawohl
und jetzt das ist uns in die richtung
gehen einfach mal mädchen vorbei
mitnehmen anna loos und angedauert
alos jetzt darüber darüber kommen wir
jetzt vorgehen vorgehen selber vorgehen
nicht warten bis sie was machen kommt
sie führen an ja ich gehe kommt nein sie
führen aber ich führe aber sie jedoch
weiter ach so ja
[Musik]
und die habe ich im griff da ordentlich
also ich habe selten so eine so eine
grazile führung ist sind man muss nur
ein bisschen dominante auftreten der
fall das würde ich so an ihnen
vorbeigehen und ich würde sie nicht
kennen würde ich sagen alter falter der
jetzt im griff
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da